[Music]
in hex on X news submitted by Android
fanboys rime don't they party of one
a New York City employee used taxpayer
money to put spells on our X Oh No who
wouldn't
we know it's legit obviously not society
I want a receipt for my taxes when
itemized receipt yeah what your taxes
are going yes and I hope it was an
effective curse yeah cuz if it didn't
work it's like man money bag consider an
effective curse that it actually
happened all right so this woman she so
she was now the former city human
resources administration employee named
Ileana and this is in New York New York
City well she latina I'm assuming cuz
her name's bak Eliana about oh yeah I
mean is there something well they
believe in magic right yeah we all do
not magic like something yeah and [ __ ]
like that then what's the difference of
magic in Santeria they called it boo boo
doo oh I might think of magic I think of
like Oh quarter you think of Harry
Potter
oh that's cool [ __ ] you think of dad
magic I got a quarter here really no
yeah we don't really know actual magic
or Las Vegas magic yeah Las Vegas magic
legit kind of bad magic magic II so what
she was doing is that she would she
would submits an emergency benefits
request that would supposedly be
perceived by someone who needed the
financial supports after an alleged
disaster but she ended up like signing
up her family members or herself to
receive this money and it totaled to
more than $300,000 subpage are a fun I
don't know how much exactly was spent
about a house of names with the rest on
the hex no right yeah I don't know
exactly how much was used but they do
report that part of
that money that she spent did on was her
ex like to put a spell on her ex that
money on the wrong which cuz that's a
lot of money and I don't know how [ __ ]
up her ex is yeah what was the spell cuz
it's gonna come back to her times three
according to the craft oh really
craft in the 90s that movie you don't
know lame
keep up G oh yeah
Peter dill would yep it was like in def
Campbell's heyday Neve Campbell is it
okay yeah like this she changes her hair
color yeah and then they do the light at
the finish and then yeah it comes back
by three yeah I did I watched it but I
think I was high I don't remember it
they were badass yeah they were I was a
good movie and then Wiccan culture got
all popular afternoon yeah yeah and
that's when charm came out yeah I was
afraid of spirits so I studied a little
bit of that [ __ ] to make the spirits go
away out of myself and that's how my
insomnia started when I was 12 years old
Wow never liked you so till this day
you're still kind of scared of spirits
no I'm not not anymore because I've
discovered science I went through my own
witch hunt when I was like 11 or 12
would you do I just started reading
online cuz I was like [ __ ] dude if these
spirits are gonna [ __ ] get me I got
to understand my enemy you're like I
gotta know their tricks so I could fight
first yeah so I went on [ __ ] into AOL
front page and then the search engine
and I said devil and I wrote down I was
like let me read what the [ __ ] does
devil say worship is let me read Wiccan
all that the different spells I will go
into the AOL chat room for witches and
[ __ ] and just read and study and I'm all
I all right what did they say they're
just talking about which [ __ ] and then I
think mainly they're a role-playing but
I didn't get it I thought they were real
witches yeah it was just some like I
don't know like they're talking about
some wizard magic sheep but I also
didn't read that well too so I was 12
and like half of the [ __ ] I understood
and then like yeah and I would just read
and see all these demon demonic pictures
and then eventually I got scared to go
to sleep at night Wow
so then I scared myself this to not
sleeping because I was originally it was
it all started because I was
afraid of Bloody Mary because I play
buddy yeah yeah my good went in the
bathroom yeah slice try to study that
and then like I try to read up on demons
and monsters and all these things and
then I guess somewhere along i
discovered drugs fast forward to being
in a part of the real world that demons
didn't scare me anymore because humans
were way more scarier than demons yeah I
believe in science
that's what conquers all supposedly they
want to take over your body demons
yeah that's why people get possessed and
stuff that's like basic excuse and then
and there in a human body and that's
what humans are really scary I always
want her to get possessed like nice
ghost
did you ever see Emily Rose of Emily
Rose I watched a scary movie with you
and I did not watch it I was on my phone
the whole time because I'm gonna die
hereditary Church no joke though I
didn't have to the last 15 minutes
masterful no but in that movie though
they actually show like real footage
watch it no I watch it by myself yeah so
what if okay so like you know how
there's like evil ghosts that come in
and like [ __ ] take yeah right what if
there's good spirits that like the holy
spirit or whatever right I mean I don't
know anything in history where there's
like a good ghost or a good like Casper
what up calls the movie yeah we cross
over so we I think as humans we only we
only recognize the negative right like
all the whole grandma she's possessed
that bitch's [ __ ] doing 360s with her
head and [ __ ] right but what if in
society we had like good ghosts that
came and possessed you and then they did
good [ __ ] and then like they left your
body like I don't know it was like what
if it was like Mother Teresa and she
said she was and she was like possessed
by a good ghost okay and if she did all
that good work and instead of like
saying she was possessed by something
great we just give the human credits
people believe that angels can work
through you yeah so like the angel will
work through a human and like help you
at like a certain time where you needed
it and then later that that human is
like I don't even know what came over me
I just felt like I needed to walk over
this direction and there you were
needing help yeah like there's stories
like that that could be yeah cuz we're
two- we're thinking about the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's throwing up in people's
faces and doing like the DAO head turns
and [ __ ] you know I think the only do
the opposite so like you know the demons
they find like the most innocent family
that just moved in so they did they
possess them I think the Angels probably
go straight into the hood and find a
group of gangsters and then whenever
they're about to do that robbery and
there's that one gangster that has like
a change of heart that's the one that's
possessed by an angel and not all the
homies questioning and another beat them
up or kill him yeah it's gotta have it
though I have one for you Joe we said
you're a man of science the horror
director John Carpenter who director you
ever watched the thing the original
month so that's a really good one but
there's one called Prince of Darkness
for everyone listing that deals with
science and it puts forth idea what if
there was no good or evil and then what
if the tale the devil actually was
something beyond good and evil and there
just was it came from some other
dimension and so there is no God there
are no angels
absolute chaos yeah is that but it's so
that one it deals in evil it deals with
a little bit but there's no then bounce
so you know like how's it go if there's
evil there have to be good it's like
it's chaos it's just whatever goes it's
chaos is just random and it's nature
right so sometimes good comes from chaos
because in order to have good you need
to have bad you can't have good by
itself it they're they're like just for
example like in nature right like you
need to destroy a force for the new
force to be born again so that's the
same thing with just humans and
relationship right like you need to feel
death or like you need to have a family
member die to also experience someone
the balance of good and bad he's saying
beyond that
good and bad there's chaos there is no
there's no concept of morality because
it's a human concept how we put oh yeah
yeah it's good this basic not all just
ethics and morality ziz shaped through
culture too as well as like biology and
what is gonna help the species survive
and stuff like that so that's what this
movies about Prince of Darkness 1987
that's a good one Prince of Darkness
1987 yeah John Carpenter is a legendary
horror director porn director but you're
just being mean about it
he directs the boys made some artistic
erotic films in most cases of things
that are spiritual or whatnot right like
that's been recorded and debunked it's
always been manipulators like very
intelligent magicians that's tricking
people all this stuff and so whatever
phenomenon exists like you can pretty
much use science to like figure it out
definitely well do you believe this
because some people believe that spirits
are just energy that we're all made up
of energy right everything in the
world's made up of energy the universe
made up of energy that spirits are just
another form of energy that's on a
different frequency and then some yeah
you know have happened but in video that
if we can't record it then it's
difficult to find it and believe it so
some people are saying they have
recorded it like with those like those
reader meters those like yeah those
meters and then they have like audio
recordings of when they can capture
different frequencies I think has to be
repeated over and over for it to be
believable right cuz it can't it could
be anything out it could be like radio
frequency it could be white noise it
could be whatever that's why I'm not
ruling it out because you know with
science it's like and the technology
gets better we can figure out
phenomenons that we couldn't before
yeah like before they thought you know
people were possessed but they were just
schizophrenic or whatever right they
thought that women having orgasms was
them going into hysteria right yeah
didn't they used to draw out blood to
cure stillness and all this crazy [ __ ]
seizures are the crazy one were that you
are not only possessed it's like
something is taking ahold of you it's
like it's actually just a cross signal
you know the
that's actually in The Exorcism of Emily
Rose when they were going in the
courtroom the therapist or counts I
forgot what it was a longtime personal
trainer maybe no she prescribed drugs
and they were like do these drugs cause
seizures because the way that she was
moving maybe it could be ruled out as a
seizure and I don't even remember what
happened but that was part of it yeah
it's all hard to say but I always want
to champion science but I do boo here's
the thing spirituality and science is
two separate things that's because it
doesn't work that way spirituality it's
based off of faith so faith is just
believing blindly and in scientists
based off evidence and facts right so
it's difficult to merge the two because
you can't argue with fate or you're not
allowed to because it goes against it
we're like kind of like that whole thing
how you were saying this schizophrenic
how they thought they were possessed by
Devils what if the devil is possessing
and it causes schizophrenia I think you
have to find that the devil exists so
it's like it's it could be true but it's
like where is the devil that's pulling
the strings yeah it's not saying it's
not true it's saying that we don't have
any evidence yet proving that it's true
yeah so it's not disproving it what I
would say is there's a guy I'm blanking
on his name who was around in the 70s
who was not only a magician he wanted to
disprove James Randi thank you yet yeah
and he had a challenge at first start
off as a thousand dollars a million
dollar challenge right maybe you could
prove that you have telekinetic powers
any ability that's beyond the normal
normal human ability he would pay you
that amount and he had people come on
and there's the guy that said he can
move like what do you want if you were
someone that had a sixth sense or
something even a sixth sense like you
could read the card that you have on the
table so what do you want to win a
million dollars I do it I got a super
power that he disproved thousands I
actually think in the modern era of
we're talking about before someone
people believing in Flat Earth and so
forth just proving a little showing a
little science would be a good idea
[Music]